nicht blicken
die zeit mit herzlich willkommen leute
ich finde es wieder you tube restmüll
sammler und euch präsentieren
ja was soll ich sagen leute weil wir
eigentlich berufsalltag in den letzten
tagen ich habe wieder mal das internet
beziehungsweise youtube durch camp nach
dem einen oder anderen patzen restmüll
in videoform und hab ihn gefunden da
dadurch die raten auf welchem
youtube-kanal ich da wohl fündig
geworden bin ja es ist es hilft mir
heute natürlich ist es hilft mir das
video dass es geht heißt mädchengang der
cool sein will muss leiden und das
besondere dieses video ist dass es
selbst auf dem hof mehrkanal besonders
heraussticht mit der anzahl an displays
dieses hat also wird wahrscheinlich was
sein was uns alle relativ stark bürgern
wird wir schauen jetzt rein und legen
los
[Musik]
ok also haben wir auf der rechten seite
unsere mädels gang
ich muss an der stelle sagen ich bin
jetzt persönlich keine fashion blogger
dazu fehlt mir natürlich die eis taut
rolex an der stelle oder anstand und was
sagen dass die schon recht brook
aussehen 16 sekunden in diesem video
drin ok abzüglich der fünf sekunden
schoss von berlin die die am anfang
gezeigt haben und sagt wie es ist mein
inneres bedürfnis beider von denen
vielleicht mal die andere backe zu
verpassen ist schon relativ hoch muss
ich sagen
vor allem sie sagt sein outfit und
beleidigt ihre augen trägt aber selbst
eine goldene bauchtasche snap beck
rückwärts und ein go [ __ ] yourself t
shirt ich glaube ich muss nicht mehr
dazu sagen
ja was soll ich sagen leute ist
natürlich eine sache die in mir
persönlich immer große sympathie auslöst
wenn ich mitbekomme dass gewisse
menschen sich über andere menschen die
am unteren ende der gesellschaft
situierte lustig machen oder wird es bei
so was also man muss wirklich bis ins
bisschen zurückhaltend hier weil das
natürlich auch eine ausgedachte fiktive
handlung aber so was kommen in mir
richtig die aggression noch also das
wirklich das allerletzte wenn ich mal
kurz mit euch ehrlich sein soll auf
menschen die sowieso schon quasi über
den schwachen sind man rumzuhacken wie
gesagt meine hand meine hand zog
gerade eben noch mit dem sein outfit
bereit unsere augen
diese kommt hat zu allem überfluss auch
noch irgendwelche glitzersteine auf der
rückseite ist sicher dass sein outfit
die augen von irgendwann beleidigt ja
wahrscheinlich dass eure straße ist die
schreckensherrschaft von diesen drei
mädels auf der rechten seite hat diese
straße im festen griff
besonders gefürchtet ist bei allen
anwohnern dieser straße das go [ __ ]
yourself t shirt wenn das am horizont
erscheint an dem in der regel allein in
die hand
nein gesagt geht woanders spielen ihr
gehören weil er so aussieht als wir dir
14 und werden mit verbundenen augen in
ein haus eingebrochen und hatte einfach
alles cloud was da so griffbereit ist
und das dann zusammen angezogen ohne
zuvor zu checken ob die farben passen
also nichts gegen h&m aber unsere augen
ich habe eure augen fühlen sich auch
beleidigt in diesem moment ich sag nur
genauso wahrscheinlich müssen die
lektionen geteilt werden
oder die lektion wird geteilt durch war
es durch zwei durch 3 jetzt wird eine
lektion geteilt aber okay ja kann man
nachvollziehen an der stelle wird ihm
eine lektion geteilt ich glaube an der
stelle sich fünf wird direktion geteilt
da haben sie dann glücklicherweise noch
mal davon abgesehen e mail lektion zu
erteilen
das werden noch das war natürlich noch
radikaler gewesen rücken sie kennt schon
sie in diesem leoparden länger jetzt ist
so der normale teil dieser gang und die
anderen beiden sind so wissen wie man
das nennt das hält man sadismus wenn man
freude am leid von anderen menschen hat
wie soll das ist eine eigenschaft die
die mich wirklich aggressiv macht selbst
wenn in so einer geschauspielert und
formen wie hier auftritt aber ja wir
müssen nach wie vor noch klären durch
was die lektion geteilt wird
ekelhaft also ich weiß nicht ich habe
nicht so viel persönlichen kontakt mit
einem berlin jetzt auch nichts gegen
österreich ist es nicht so aber dinger
diesen 13 vom für die sich so auf als
ich 13 war habe ich so zu den
erwachsenen 18 jährigen so aufgeschaut
wird die turn ich mal lieber karten also
ich gehe mal davon aus leute dass es
euch ähnlich geht also wenn man sowas
sieht dann kicken glaube ich bei den
allermeisten menschen die aggressionen
rein und ich suche aber für so ein bild
was ich so gerne mit keine ahnung den
anstellen würde aber können wir für den
anfang vielleicht so ein so einen
kleinlaster haben der einfach so von
rechts zufolge kann sich das bild
brettert und die drei probleme beseitigt
so wirklich nicht schlecht
okay da sind sie schon beim
einkaufszentrum angekommen hier an der
stelle zu sehen
nur ist es kein einkaufszentrum ist es
so wie eine ruine zum verlassen das haus
wenn man einmal diese outfits gesehen
hat dann muss man keine weiteren frage
stellt das ist mein ding ja ich kann es
auch angst co das ist der richtige gang
dass leute dass die sprache die die
gangs in berlin sprechen die die straßen
terrorisieren ok sachen sind es cool das
ist übrigens genau wie das go [ __ ] is s
t shirt wenn diese ausdrucken school
akustisch vernommen wird von den
bewohnern der innstraße der die rennen
rein bis über pearl spielfilm alle rein
in die häuser rollladen runter lassen
sich über blick nicht so gut gemacht und
dafür bekommt sie natürlich eine
belohnung von mona gehörst du zu unserer
gehen wie sie darauf abstellt dass wir
einfach so gold farben angemalt das
plastik dollarzeichen umgehängt und was
jetzt bin ich mitglied der gang
du meinst die game die mit mir dann
ganze drei mitglieder alter also ich
finde sie hat sich noch nicht genug
bewiesen
du weißt sehen penner daran gemacht hat
und für sie dieses haar band geklaut hat
natürlich war das fahrrad geklaut hat
ich hoffe dass ich davon ausgehen dass
das haus gekauft wurde
wer kauft den was in der gang halo ist
die gang für die folge moment mal du
hast jemand nicht zu mögen wenn ich sage
dass du mit ihm gehabt
also ich will dich so sehr hasst du
details rumreiten aber sollte das outfit
von der opfer dieser medien der mitte
ist auch das ist kein genuss okay also
es ist schon sehr stark 80er lustig
gefühlt sondern aber die da rechts ich
meine dies dies vom gesicht herzlich
hässlich würde ich eigentlich schon
hübsch kann man sagen aber die hat
dieses outfit sieht so aus wissen wir
dass aussieht es sieht so aus als hätte
jemand versucht leute sauer zu machen
also nach dem motto wie man sich über
ein anziehen und mit dem outfit leute
möglichst sauber zu
so sieht es aus mihla hat sich gerade
strafbar gemacht nur um 2 an der gruppe
gehören zu können
sie ist zwar erst 17 und liegt damit
aber auf jeden fall den regeln des
jugendstrafrechts der rechtsanwalt
experte hat auf jeden fall noch nicht
für die gegen von ufo und das gehört pro
hallo für die gänge für die gang für die
gelenke natürlich mit seinem
rechtsanwalt künftiger was die
ausgeklappt hat und du du hast nur ein
paar ohrringe geklaut und außerdem wenn
ich sage dass sie dazu gehört gehört
sagt okay also scheinbar verdient man
sich street crash in dieser gang in dem
man sachen cloud und wer mehr cloud ist
wie der beste die bessere der also wie
gesagt wird diese theorie mit augen
verbunden im h&m das outfit
zusammengeklaut das ist glaube ich gar
nicht so abwegig ja du hast mir jetzt
auch mit so einer schlechten ausrede
anzukommen
du warst wetter einfach schlecht und das
ist fakt zunächst mal wird es besser
laufen versprochen
das hoffe ich also die frage ist ja
eigentlich so was passiert wenn jemand
in dieser gegend sich falsch verhält so
also was man machen sie irgendjemand
rausschmeißen so breit schon 0 3
ok wenn er eine person rausschmeißt
verliert auf einen schlag 33 prozent
teurer gang
aber er läutet die kontrollieren die
straßen da darf man sich nicht drüber
lustig machen cofaktor hashtags 11 6 11
wie alter als
ich war also ich weiß wirklich nicht ob
ich mich zum modethemen auslassen sollte
ich mir jetzt auch keine keinen fashion
youtuber oder so da irgendwann irgendwie
high fashion und sonstigen geschichten
drin aber pro kopf was das sein soll
aber das passt halt einfach nicht rein
richtig gut
das nicht zumal muss sie weiter so
machen noch okay jetzt stecke ich das
also sieht links ist quasi die gegnerin
und die anderen zahllosen zwei
mitglieder der restlichen mitglieder die
sind natürlich von ihrer anführerin
schwer beeindrucken clown für die und ja
die anführerin sagt sich dann den ganzen
das ganze diebesgut 1 wie natascha sich
hier verhält hat mit freundschaft nichts
zu tun
freundinnen sind gleichberechtigt
hoffentlich merkt mila bald was ihre
angebliche freundin hier abzieht
richtig so gut dass wir an der stelle
die hilfe expertin haben freunde sollten
die bis gut untereinander verteilen und
dass wir an der stelle natürlich nicht
darüber auslassen das einfach alles was
da liegt geklaut ist das dann gegen
geltendes recht in deutschland verstoßen
wurde in nicht unerheblichem umfang das
ist mir egal hauptsache das diebesgut
wird geteilt mainka man unter freunden
[Musik]
ok go jetzt geht's weiter also die
straßen werden terrorisiert sicher ist
sie rappt einfach die gelder für die
gänge okay guck mal so dass plastik die
dollarzeichen aus dem ein euro laden
zusammen glänzen okay du kennst uns auf
den straßen wissen dass wir haben nicht
mal einen namen für unsere gelten aber
mit mädchen gang
aber wir sind ok lass uns in ruhe wir
sind doch gerade und dieser kriege
vorbei glaubt mir können sie doch
sowieso nie schneiden
wie wäre es wenn wir etwas ab das ist
eine gute idee ist eine schlechte idee
ich werde euch einfach zur abwechslung
man normal verhalte die normale menschen
hier gewesen bist ihr einfach auf so
eine art und weise wo man jetzt nicht
als normaler mensch egal ob mann oder
frau ist das bedürfnis verspürt euch
eine saftige respekt städte zu geben
doch was brauchst du dich hier nicht zu
kommen ich möchte dass du das schabracke
die tasche weg okay ich mache der stern
hat wir haben jetzt genau die hälfte von
diesem sehr wertvollen mädchengang video
durch ich bin selbst was diese drei in
der nächsten folge die in zwei tagen
übermorgen kommt noch an unter menschen
verhalten an den tag legen werden
hier könnte es da nicht schon mal für
euch das video abchecken und hier oben
ein kanal bei dem man sich das video
gefallen hat das war so weit von mir
meine erste liebe grüße aus dem urlaub
ich größere augen leute macht's gut bis
zum nächsten mal